I'm Brett Baer I'm Maria Bartiromo I'm
Brian Kilmeade and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday December 7th 2022 I'm Lisa
Brady an old covid debate comes back
around on Capitol Hill just as the U.S
military is struggling to meet
recruiting goals so the covid vaccine
layered on top of the other issues is
just making what could have been just a
difficult year you know a crisis I'm
Dave Anthony the attack that knocked out
power in North Carolina as utilities
everywhere reevaluating security what
everybody fears most is that there is an
outage an attack whether it's physical
or cyber that would cause what they call
a cascading outage and I'm Carol
Markowitz I've got the final word on the
Fox News Rundown
[Music]
how the U.S military operates including
how it spends money is in limbo for now
with an annual policy Bill held up in
Congress partly over A Renewed debate
about the military's covet vaccine
mandate Republicans making a renewed
push for that mandate to be repealed
Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
calls that befuddling coveted vaccines
have saved lives the military has had
requirements about other vaccines for
decades and there hasn't been a problem
house Democrats agreed to remove the
Mandate from the policy bill that
version would not reinstate service
members discharged for not getting
coveted shots but a provision would ask
the Pentagon to study potential remedies
for members who were kicked out or had
benefits cut Senate minority leader
Mitch McConnell accuses Democrats of
holding the National Defense
authorization act hostage with
non-defense related items the Democrats
failure to plan ahead for unrelated
liberal pet priorities should not be
creating uncertainty and confusion
for the brave service members who keep
us safe one of the items he singles out
previously failed in the Senate a
permitting reform proposal that
McConnell says is reform and name only
and that faces some bipartisan
opposition as well all of this adds up
to another round of beat the clock on
Capitol Hill facing year-end deadlines
on more than one bill including the ndaa
it's the thing that defines the policy
and the authorizations for an entire
year of the United States military so
it's it's very important without it many
new programs cannot start retired army
lieutenant general Tom spoor is director
of The Heritage foundation's Center for
National Defense the new policies that
the Pentagon was hoping to put in place
are frozen into last year's
authorization so there's really no
forward progress without a National
Defense authorization act right it's
really it's not the money but it's it
enables how the money is spent right is
that yeah exactly and it provides the
guidance from Congress on how they think
the military should be organize and
operate and so from that point of view
you know usually it has a number of
improvements and reforms and so without
those the Pentagon is just stuck in the
old way of doing business
so now we come to the debate over the
vaccine mandate in the military which
initially was in the bill and apparently
Democrats have agreed with Republicans
pressing to strip that out of the bill
which means there would no longer be a
covid vaccine mandate in the military
how important is that debate I mean
thousands of service members have
already been let go because of that
mandate yeah we're in the midst of the
worst recruiting crisis that the
military's had since the start of the
all-volunteer force and so the covid
Mandate is is preventing people that are
reluctant to get the vaccine from
entering and it's also leading to the
discharge of thousands of service
members and so from just a Manpower
point of view alone it's really
important this year I think to to get
this settled
what about the argument though that this
could open up the rest of the military
vaccine mandates to challenges because
there are a variety of vaccine
requirements in the military right oh
yeah there's at least nine mandatory
vaccines I recall getting yellow fever
and diseases I really had never heard of
but when you're a young Soldier they
just March you into the hospital and you
get whatever they tell you you need I
you know these other vaccines in my
experience have never really been
controversial so I don't I don't know I
can't predict that whether this will
open up new challenges to those vaccines
I've never heard anybody even other than
not wanting to get the anthrax shot
because it really hurt when it went in
I've never really heard anybody Express
you know displeasure or disagreement
with getting one of these other vaccines
do you think that transmissibility could
be folded into this debate because the
CDC really acknowledges now that you
know the covet vaccine doesn't
necessarily stop trans Mission you can
get vaccinated and still end up catching
it but it's just supposed to lessen the
severity of it lessen the risk of death
and serious illness is that a dividing
line between this and some of those
other vaccines yeah I think I think
that's too and again you know we have
moved on and our understanding of coven
and the other part that people don't
talk about is that the military is
usually composed of young people you
know most of them are below the age of
30 who are the group that are at least
risk from covid especially from any
Syria you know they'll catch it but they
won't have any serious consequence of it
so you you have to put that into the mix
and decide whether or not the Mandate is
worth it when it's resulting in the loss
of all these either potential or people
that are already in the military I know
a big part of the reasoning behind it I
seem to remember was Readiness I guess
what hurts Readiness more in your
opinion not having everyone vaccinated
or having fewer troops because of the
mandate
I think today we're looking at the fewer
troops argument you know the Army in
2022 failed to recruit what it needed to
and so they are shrinking in size
they're getting smaller as we watch them
and they're not only that but then the
soldiers that they're discharging and
this is a phenomenon extending to all
the services I was at the uh Reagan
Defense Forum this past weekend and
general Berger the Marine Corps
commandant talked about at least
20 to 30 percent of young people haven't
gotten a covid vaccine and don't intend
to and so that's a population that is
really excluded from potential military
service and can we put it into context
for people when we say recruitment is
down maybe just sticking with the Army
as an example
how much are we talking about yeah so in
the last fiscal year 2022 they had hoped
at the start to recruit some 70 000
people into the service and they they
were able to recruit less than fifty
thousand so they missed their goal by at
least 25
000 soldiers and so it's not getting
better either in 2023 they think it's
going to be worse and they're prepared
for an army that is much smaller than
the one we have now and so this this
recruiting crisis and we're in the midst
of right now shows no signs of abating
do we have any sense though of how much
a factor the vaccine mandate is with
that or are other issues more of a
factor when it comes to recruiting
problems yeah I don't think it is the
main factor the main factor is probably
the you know the overall shortage of
people to work the talent with the war
for talent is really strong and so you
can see many businesses and corporations
trying to hire people but when you're in
the midst of a crisis every little thing
hurts and so the covid vaccine layered
on top of the other issues is just
making what could have been just a
difficult year you know a crisis
in addition to the overall military
numbers what are the effects of a
recruiting shortage for instance our
service members not able to specialize
in certain areas because there are fewer
people to fill positions
yeah that is one impact and so if you'd
come in and you wanted to be cyber or a
cook or anyone of a million occupations
that the military has the military has
to decide first to fill their most
critical shortages so you may not have
that option I mean the other things that
are going to come from this are units
military units are going to be short
ships are going to be short Sailors the
Air Force is going to be short Pilots
for their planes and the Army is going
to be short soldiers for their combat
units they're battalions and their
brigades and so
you know you have to be ready at a
moment's notice and these units with
these shortages are going to be less
ready than they were a couple of years
ago
today is December 7th
um in terms of recruitment military
Readiness would you be worried that
America you know would be ready if there
were ever another Pearl harbor-like
attack
I am I'm worried right now and it
doesn't have to be
a Pearl Harbor attack it can be any one
of a number of different scenarios and
unfortunately history shows that every
20 years or so the U.S military gets
itself into some sort of a conflict or
war and so that time is coming and we
don't get the luxury of deciding where
and when it's going to happen we have to
be ready at all times and so this
decline we're seeing which really has no
forecasted end right now is very
worrisome the White House has said the
president agrees with the defense
secretary that it's important for all
Americans to be vaccinated against covid
there does seem to be some bipartisan
pressure building though on this mandate
issue would you be hopeful about this
effort to lift the vaccine mandate at
this point
it's a great question so you know I'm
looking out my window at the halls of
Congress right now and they are as we
speak debating that very provision so
it's hard to say how it's going to come
out there are very strong feelings on
both sides I think there's reason you
know the latest news as you said at the
start is that we think there is a repeal
of the vaccine mandate in the National
Defense authorization act whether that
holds till the very end and is signed
into law by the president I think is
anybody's guess at this moment should
Americans be concerned or are you
concerned when either side in Washington
holds up this particular authorization
bill for any reason you know no matter
what the issue is
first off I would say the defense
authorization act has been wildly
delayed I mean both houses of Congress
were essentially done with this bill in
June maybe July at the latest and for
reasons that are inexplicable to me it
has been delayed now and here we are in
December talking about this when this
should have been disposed of months ago
I'm one of these people that favors
quality over quantity so I would if
there were some legitimate warfighting
concerns that were still being debated
about the National Defense authorization
act I'd be willing to delay it but
that's not what's happening right now
they're arguing over things that have
nothing to do with our national offense
but have been attached to this
legislation for reasons of expediency
and to hope that it will help them pass
when they might not have passed on their
own
at the same time we have Russia's war in
Ukraine continuing generating a lot of
military assistance from the U.S for
Ukraine the deputy secretary of state
Wendy Sherman says the U.S has enough of
a stockpile to keep helping Ukraine with
drawdowns of military assistance
historically how big is that stockpile
the stockpile is good it's adequate it's
probably the biggest stockpile of any
country in the world but it's it's going
to come short in some cases you know as
famously you've heard that we've used up
a third of our Javelin missiles and a
quarter of our Stinger missiles and that
was months ago and so we continue to
draw those down whereas production for
these Munitions is just now beginning to
start and so we are getting close to the
levels where we should be concerned are
those things also part of what's
authorized in the bill
yeah that's a great question so there
and not only are these things authorized
in that bill but there's reforms there's
more money there's ways to accelerate
and make our Munitions producers more
effective by investing in their Capital
uh buildings and their tools so I think
you know every day that we don't get
this National Defense authorization Act
is another day that our production
capabilities don't rise to meet the
occasion
what would you say to any Americans
concerned about the overall state of the
US military we hear a lot about you know
the moves that China's making to beef up
its own military and build it bigger and
bigger but you hear our U.S defense
leaders saying you know America still
has the finest fighting force in the
world what would you say to concerned
Americans well there's two things that
are two at the same time we the United
States has the best military in the
world Bar None it's leaders and its
equipment is is excellent on the other
hand I would say our U.S military is not
adequate to what we have defined in our
national strategies to deter both China
Russia Iran and North Korea requires a
bigger military than we have right now
more ships the most of our military
experts tell us we need 400 Navy ships
and we have about 290 today and so while
our military is excellent it isn't big
nor modern enough right now retired army
lieutenant general Tom spoor director of
The Heritage foundation's Center for
National Defense events thank you very
very much for your time it was my
pleasure thank you
[Music]
Harry coming up
it has been a tough week in a part of
North Carolina known for great golf
courses and retirement living the
Pinehurst area where a lot of people
have been without power for days and in
many cases that also means no heat on
chilly below freezing nights after an
attack on power substations no group has
stepped up to acknowledge or accept it
they're the ones that done it so yeah I
call them cowards Moore County Sheriff
Ronnie Fields is getting help from the
FBI White House Press Secretary Kareem
John Pierre says we condemn a this
apparent attack on critical
infrastructure federal law enforcement
continues to support the investigation
and we will continue to monitor the
situation as that investigation plays
out the attack on Saturday cut the power
to about 45
000 homes and businesses I want to thank
the people who are working so hard
to restore power it's very complex what
they're doing and they've been working
around the clock to do that Governor Roy
Cooper says they've also brought in
generators to Care Homes and facilities
in need in Moore County while the attack
itself has utilities everywhere
reassessing security every once in a
while we get these really nasty
reminders that it is a fairly fragile
certainly interconnected
system Michael Balboni is president of
Redland strategies a utility security
expert who used to chair the homeland
security committee as a state senator in
New York
and what everybody fears most is that
there is an outage an attack whether
it's physical or cyber that would cause
what they call a cascading outage we saw
that in I believe in 2004 when a tree
limb hit a power line in Ohio and caused
a cascading effect all throughout the
Northeast
what happened in uh over this weekend it
just began at seven o'clock on on
Saturday night yeah in Moore County was
that you had an individual or
individuals who gained access to the
site of a substation
and the relevance there is that there
are 50 approximately 55 000 substations
throughout the nation
and so if you take out one of the
substations you're going to affect
varying sizes of population in terms of
their power
in the end it seems to me in a world
where we have all this cyber Espionage
and cyber threat they just go in and
they start shooting it's pretty simple
in some ways and they attack a
substation so I assume you can do an
awful lot of damage doing that
well that that's what they demonstrated
and um what we know so far you know the
FBI is investigating no arrests have
been made so far and the Moore County
attack on the substation but we do know
that it was a rifle fire and we do know
that uh there was a gate that was
intentionally taken off of the hinges to
gain access to the facility you know two
different attacks different times in the
same station I'm sorry two different
substations so it was not something
there uh where there was an errant
bullet that came from a hunter site or
something like that not not at all this
was a targeted attack on these two
substations
there certainly are people who are out
there that have been studying this and
wanting to do this very kind of damage
and I'm sure I know over the years
you've been studying them
well I I think what what is happening
here is obviously different motivation
different ideologies the Department of
Homeland Security has has issued reports
talking about a domestic terrorism
Target and one of the chances I I get a
chance to sit on the uh domestic
terrorism task force for New York State
and
um we have been looking at the whole
issue of domestic terrorism and what we
realize is that there's a lot of
different ideological perspectives on
this motivations and there is some
indication that you know some of there
are lone wolves or coordinated groups
that we seek to take down
portions of the power grid in 2020 there
came out a document it was 14 pages long
and it was put together by groups with
the goal of trying to attack critical
infrastructure and it's a how-to guide
and part of it is how you use guns and
armor-piercing rounds to go into
Transformers to destroy them
I assume that's been part of the work on
securing facilities trying to study that
guide
you know the uh there are always three
different things that you take a look at
in terms of an attack one is is the does
the individual have the access do they
have the means and do they have the
motivation so that document provided the
last aspect of that which is the
motivation
going forward though the question
becomes is is this the only threat you
know and the and the answer that is no
it's not there's a cyber security threat
that has been evidenced by the FBI for a
very long time there's a concern
particularly after uh you had a
particular attack in cyber called solar
winds which the malware was in the
system for a very long time and it was
doing surveillance and the question is
is there malware from say a foreign
State actor
in our utility grids so there's a lot of
concerns about this the question becomes
what's the ultimate goal to take down
the entire system that sounds uh like
the self-defeating goal unless you just
want Anarchy and some do obviously some
summers are hoping for that but and it
wouldn't take long right if if the
population was out of power for a week
we've seen movies like this
yeah you know interesting so I lived
through Sandy here in New York and that
was always a concern if the power went
out and um then you had freezing
temperatures which is exactly what
happened in the Sandy hurricane
um you know what would people do there
was uh you know it was it was a very
large hurricane but there was a limit
kind of limited area but people are able
to survive you got to go back to the
days before you had you know the kind of
luxuries and and conveniences we have
now but for a short period of time you
could do this the question is are the
things that you could do to the grid
where you would take it out for you know
six months or a year and that's really
the thing that's the prioritization that
folks who operate utilities have focused
on to prevent that if they are able to
take out the internet and they're able
to take out our phone service and then
you can't get gas out of the ground
those are the kinds of things uh and you
can't access your bank account those are
the things that that lead to the chaos
right right it's very unlikely that you
could have one one attack that that were
a series of attacks that would that
would result in that kind of a
catastrophic event itself what happened
in North Carolina is smaller potatoes
compared to the attack in California in
2013 that is still unsolved to this day
and it's closely studied by the
utilities industry first they cut fiber
optic cables then they started shooting
not just damaging the infrastructure
also spilling a giant oil drum used to
help cool high voltage lines then they
fled when police arrived what happened
was there was a substation that fed
Silicon Valley and in Metcalf California
and there were two elements of the
attack the first is that the attackers
gained access to a vault a cable Vault
and for the substation and a cut cable
and then proceeded to pour sniper fire
onto the substation estimated 200 rounds
were fired taking out various uh
elements of the substation so the
individuals obviously had detailed
inside information as to how the
substation worked where the
vulnerabilities were and they took
advantage of that information now you
they haven't caught anybody how long was
there an outage there
um it was it was a very long time I mean
luckily they were able to do a a
workaround and bring other power grids
up up to speed so they could provide
Power but it was a it was a long time
and it sent a shock wave through the
entire utility industry especially the
northeastern reliability Council which
is called nerc is is one of the um
foremost Regulators of the utility and
they put out a critical infrastructure
protection requirement of the physical
um have to the physical security steps
you have to take to secure a substation
okay so that led to more security than
what happened in North Carolina I mean
how'd they get through a gate I mean how
much security is there and and so it
makes me wonder how much security there
all there is in these facilities well
again you know they can be remote they
can be at a place where
um the you don't necessarily have eyes
on the target the entire time again 55
000 you're going to varying degrees of
access
which is the big concern you know now
I've assure you that since those attacks
and more there is now a re-examination
of the security posture in all utilities
and their substations and that's going
on right now and that's not a question
in North Carolina right that means
everywhere that's across the country
so more security physically there more
surveillance maybe I mean both yeah so
it's you know what I refer to as a
guards Gates guns and gadgets you don't
really put a guard by a substation
analysis absolutely critically important
but but you know technology of having
the cameras having uh really good Gates
shielding the most vulnerable aspects of
the substation from things like right
you know sniper fire
um being able to have a rapid response
capability should someone detect it in
the area these are all the key
components to infrastructure protection
so the most immediate concern is that
someone's going to take a look at this
now is viral on the internet and say
well why don't I just go take a gun and
see what I could do you know maybe let
me try it and and not have any of the
ideological issues and therefore not be
on you know Facebook or Tick Tock or
anything like that saying that they're
going to do this that's always the the
most dangerous scenario because you
never see it coming that's one of my
principal concerns when you have an
event like this so what do you think is
a bigger threat
a physical attack like what happened to
North Carolina or something in the cyber
world something like Russia or North
Korea might do
I think it's the Cyber threat is is much
more prevalent especially after what we
saw in a Ukraine back in 2018
where you know you can't pinpoint
somebody who's the specific attacker but
we'll assume it was Russia that launched
an attack on New Year's right before New
Year's Eve and took out two power plants
in in uh I think it was around TF
and um yeah obviously Prelude possibly
to the upcoming attacks do you see that
kind of capability
um it makes you really wonder whether or
not that's something that um Utilities
in the United States could be vulnerable
to so I personally having studied this
for a while I think that that's that's
his biggest threat but you don't
discount any threats you try to respond
and be prepared for every threat to the
extent that you can
generally speaking though do you think
our infrastructure is safe I think our
infrastructure is secure because of of
monitoring can can we do better we can
always do better the threats evolve we
need to evolve with them Michael Balboni
president managing director of Redland
strategies former Homeland Security
advisor for New York State thank you so
much for joining us my pleasure thank
you
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi 2022
is coming to a close and as we look back
on the here it's time to reflect on some
key themes Merriam-Webster and Oxford
English dictionaries released their
words of the year and it seems like they
had some different takeaways Oxford
English dubbed Goblin mode the word or
phrase really of the year it's a slang
term referring to quote a type of
behavior which is unapologetically
self-indulgent lazy or greedy typically
in a way that rejects social norms or
expectations it encourages people to
lean into their uncurated self-indulgent
and sometimes mischievous ways the
phrase was chosen by way of online vote
winning 93 of the 340 000 votes cast it
beat out metaverse and hashtag I stand
with Oxford reps credit pandemic
lockdowns to shifts an attitude and say
this year's phrase acknowledges that
we're not always our most idealized
curated selves that we portray on social
media last week Merriam-Webster
announced its word of the year was
gaslighting defined as psychological
manipulation of a person usually over an
extended period of time that causes the
victim to question the validity of their
own thoughts a tactic used by abusers
and relationships or even corporations
as a way to mislead the public there's
also medical gaslighting we're a health
care professional dismisses the
patient's symptoms as something all in
your head lookups for the word on
merriamwebster.com increased 1 740
percent in 2022 over the year before
unlike Oxford mariam's word of the year
was not selected by the people last year
the two dictionaries saw more eye to eye
2021 Oxford's word of the year was vax
Merriam-Webster's was vaccine for the
Fox News rundown I'm Gian jalosi
foreign
[Music]
Fox News Radio On Demand on the Fox News
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite Fox News talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
Fox News Radio newscasts On Demand Fox
News Radio and the Fox News app download
it today Raiden review the Fox News
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen it's time for your Fox News
commentary Carol Markowitz what's on
your mind first comes love then comes
marriage then comes baby in the baby
carriage right what if Americans stop
playing that out
America is heading toward a birth rate
crisis a new Institute for family
studies analysis of 2020 census data
found one in Six Women reached the end
of their childbearing years hasn't given
birth
this is a growing concern for the
country in 2007 the average number of
children per woman was 2.7 by 2020 it
was already 1.6
already Senator Chuck Schumer is looking
to fix our population plunge by granting
citizenship to all illegal immigrants
the problem actually goes beyond birth
rates the focus on childbearing obscures
a different Calamity marriage rates are
in collapse relationships in general are
harder to come by a 2020 Pew study found
35 percent of never married single men
and 37 percent of never married single
women had never even been in a committed
relationship that's a lot of people on
their own
in August a rather tame Psychology today
article about the rise of lonely single
men went inexplicably viral writer Greg
Matos noting men are increasingly single
said the broad trends of their
over-representation on dating apps and
lack of dating skills along with women's
Rising standards don't pretend well for
the future of men finding love Mattel's
piece hit a nerve across the internet as
women mock the idea that their higher
standards had left more men single but
women of course are just as single and
will face the same problems as men part
of the issue is that the Splendor of
family life is often a well-kept secret
we read articles about how wonderful it
is to be single and see social media
posts celebrating the fun of singlehood
comedian Chelsea Handler often posts to
her social media how fantastic it is to
have the bed all to herself and how much
she enjoys having no weekend obligations
but just like boys don't wear boys Run
the World t-shirts and the Richer a
person is the less likely she'll be
wearing designer logos on across her
clothing it would be gosh for people in
happy relationships to let the world
know the truth
it's impossible to imagine a comedian
making regular videos about how thrilled
he is to be married in fact when a
couple is a little too open about their
hashtag blessed relationship on social
media we immediately suspect things
aren't actually going that well offline
the result is that people only see the
bad side of marriage and family their
married friends don't sit around over
margaritas praising their spouses few
talk about how amazing and fulfilling it
is to have children
instead people highlight the struggles
of marriage and family so as not to make
anyone else feel bad about how
incredible it actually is we hear about
only the negative aspects of family and
only the absolutely Blissful parts of
singlehood
it's no wonder one has started to grow
in popularity over the other when people
realize they've been lied to it might be
too late
so married people do your friends a
favor and don't hide your happiness tell
the truth about the bad times but don't
pretend there aren't many good ones Rave
about your spouse behind his or her back
be honest about how fun it is to have
children nothing is ever perfect whether
you're single or married it doesn't have
to be let's just be real about how good
it can be this is Carol Marco with
columnist for the New York Post
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
listen to the all-new Brett Bear podcast
featuring Common Ground in-depth talks
with lawmakers from opposite sides of
the aisle along with all your bear
favorites like his All-Star panel and
much more available now at
foxnewspodcasts.com or wherever you get
your podcasts